hey ho minecraft freunde willkommen zu
einer weiteren folge von minecraft nero
heute zusammen wird klar crafter hey was
geht und ich muss an gehen direkt auf
dem server ich bin mega gespannt und ich
glaube wir können einiges schaffen so
wäre das hoffe ich doch mal ja eben hast
du ihn gerade auch dieses komische
geräusche hört also bei mir war so
richtig laut ist zwischen ganz kurz
neben mir nicht also vielleicht sind wir
sind wir auch ein bisschen entfernt
weißt du deine koordinaten komme also
wenn ich gott hier ist etwas in die luft
geflogen
also ich f3 drücke dann habe ich sie ja
ich bin bei 217 11 - 1646 an die 2169
ist das oben foto oh gott ich bin ich
bin viel weiter weg also ich guck ich
bin ja noch in der höhle ich gucke ich
mich noch hier oben
ich bin ja noch anschauen ob das jetzt
so eine mega höhle soll ich mich direkt
zu mir und dann gucke ich mal gerne ich
jetzt hier schon mal die gelegenheit
habe aber ich glaube ich weiß von wo
kann ich denn hier ich bin mir unsicher
ja also wir haben auf jeden fall heute
uns schon mal gemeinsam vorgenommen dass
wir uns diese diesen antic atlas also
die minimap sozusagen machen
die geht ganz einfach mit einem buch und
einem kompass zu kräften
und das ist halt relativ praktisch dass
man sich gegenseitig findet und ich bin
mir nicht sicher ob man sich darauf
nicht sogar sachen markieren kann
irgendwie wie aus einer richtigen
minimap aber jetzt muss ich meinen weg
raus finden weil ich habe kein kann holz
mitgenommen das hastig ich mache es
immer wieder
es ist immer das gleiche ja das kenne
ich union ist so gut also ich habe
deswegen noch einmal volle aufnahme
woraufhin der letzten aufnahme noch mal
ein baum gefällt bevor ich unter bin ja
das ist schlau insoweit habe ich nicht
gedacht ich habe es immer wieder
immer wenn ich mein kreuz spiel
irgendwie so im singleplayer dann bin
ich immer so euphorisch weil ich etwas
cooles gefunden habe oder so aber man
weiß ja auch nie was genau kommt und
irgendwie habe ich das gefühl dass ihr
wollt in meiner rolle hier drin war und
alles total anders ist alles anders aus
aber ich hab' ich hab ja glück hier ist
hier der mannschaft da kann ich mir
einfach ein bisschen holz abbauen ich
war letzte stunde mit vertritt letzte
stunde sache schon letzte folge mit
patrick habe ich ja mein system gefunden
die kiste habe ich schon genug noch
einige und hier habe ich zum schluss
habe ich ein bisschen was gefunden sehr
gut ja ich werde auf jeden fall in
meiner folge schon den blut alter bauen
heute das fing ja das klingt auf jeden
fall heftig also ich werde nur mich auf
diamanten suche begeben und so ein wenig
vielleicht mit anderen ort monstern
kämpfen
da ist schon als wenig um monster
spreche ich habe den namen nicht gesehen
aber ich hab's getötet ich habe noch
viereinhalb herzen und ich hab ich was
bekomme ich gekommen weil ich schwarz
arbeitet das coole bei dem bei den mac
ist wenn man mit monstern kämpft kann es
einfach rennen passieren dass einem die
übelsten op waffen gedruckt werden
die meisten waffen die aus dem bei
advance auf den zehnten hinzugefügt
werden sind einfach random drops also
nicht nicht ganz rechnung hat wenn du
manche besonderen gegner besiegt dann
droppen halt bessere waffen und so
weiter und so fort aber vor allem sind
das erste mal halt einfach drop sie kann
man sich nicht kräften die meisten
waffen so und wenn du zum beispiel so
ein
wie heißt er noch so ein wortschatz
charger sind diese zweibeinigen hühnchen
die was mir schon mal ins gesehen hast
von denen kein hühnchen wirklich münchen
wir sehen die nur ausführlich
diese hängt natürlich gerade das auch
wieder auch aus münchen war auch glaube
ich nur zweibeiner kann er so ein großes
ding das total aggressiv um sprintet ich
weiß welche du meinst die habe ich
letzte folge glaube ich schon gesehen
ja genau die die dinger haben mir als
ich so ein bisschen ausprobiert hat
das gibt's nicht einfach eingebaut doch
dieser treffer drohte mich verdammt
spannend was mach ich jetzt vom server
gehen musst du ja ich bin runter
verdammt man was okay zweite folge
erster tod woher kommen die ganzen
bollstedt aber eigentlich alles
ausgeleuchtet das ist genau so wie du
ihr meint es plötzlich es ist nicht böse
stadt gar nicht gut für unsere stadt und
auch nicht für die aufgabe gerade
verdammt ich hatte ja eben die
koordinaten offen ich könnte theoretisch
nachgucken könntest du hingehen aber ach
stimmt deine sachen oder wie ja meine
sachen link da ja eigentlich kann ich
retten ja genau du könntest du dir grab
stand entweder den screenshot ich mir
immer hier die höhle wo ich hin ja dann
machen wir das doch direkt okay dann
sie konnte ich muss mich bei meiner
aufnahme cut machen und dann gucken wir
mal wie es mit der wiederbelebung läuft
ich muss mich die koordinaten aussuchen
ja nächste folge musste dann trotzdem
aber aussetzen
meine hochladen oder vom zum hochladen
der frau aufnehmen durfte man ja genau
erstmalig in die koordinaten auf schmerz
ist gesagt hast ja ich habe jetzt die
koordinaten von der stelle wo ich vor
sie habe vor also in diesen paar blöcke
davon entfernt aber das wird schon
passen
ok dann probiere ich das hier erstmals
zu finden
ich glaube an meine zuschauer
wir müssen erstmal kaum retten ich danke
danke ich glaube aber ich werde trotzdem
den blatter auf jeden fall hinkriegen in
der folge so dass die mich geschickt
nein ich hab doch solche tabs an gehabt
was hattest du an die caps also des
wegen krawallen in den teams lippstädter
siehst du was ich geschickt sie könne
das waren wir nicht auf
hast du sie achte stück musste er von
hand abschreiben wiesbaum ich jetzt mal
unvorsichtige hierauf mal dass mir das
nicht zum verhängnis wird
duell auf diesen schon ein paar blöcke
von hier entfernt also deine klangen
vorhin auf jeden fall schon so fünf bis
sechs neue blöcke weit weg keine ahnung
zwei kleine aber ich bin eigentlich in
relativer nähe von der stadt geblieben
ok ja ich eigentlich auch also ich bin
bei einem beschluss also ich guck mal
ich habe 2001 22 bisher direkt also fast
selber koordinate und -2 1614 es passt
wir sind wahrscheinlich sogar dasselbe
höhle wir waren bestimmt in derselben
höhe deswegen seine höhle gerade anderes
auch weil ich weiss es wert aber ich
glaube ich baue michael war meine ist
direkt an einer wasserstelle bei unserer
stadt gelegen also da bin dass es direkt
an der oberfläche eigentlich bin ich
gestorben
da hab ich ja okay du hast auch höhe 22
deshalb baue ich mich jetzt auch am
besten mal direkt an die oberfläche und
probiere ich zu retten ich muss aber
auch gleichzeitig die folgen länger ein
bisschen im auge war will ich glaube
nach fünf minuten die spannende sachen
und du musst auch oft nicht dass du auch
noch stirbt ja das wird es wäre richtig
mies waren ja zwei von solchen fächern
aber ich hatte den einstein eigentlich
angehört sind aber hast du hattest du
schon rüstung an gar nicht na gut ich
hab schon voll
und equipment darum gerade wer weiß
vielleicht drop mir sogar irgendwas
besonderes wenn ich die mobs töte so ok
dass wir müssen es schaffen dass du
deine folge noch fertig machen kannst
das wetter habe ich bin schon denn schon
bei erde um ok heißt war schon ab sodann
top-duo wasser findet eine runde massa
stellte weil die leute direkt zur stelle
wo ich gestorben bin so ich bin wieder
an der oberfläche
so hat mich umschauen dass hier keine
monster sind okay so ich muss zu 2131
das passt so weit okay nicht die
richtung und wie gesagt wenig davon weg
du musst dir höhleneingang am besten
finden ok jetzt schon in die richtige
richtung so an der wasserstelle sagte
schöne
genau an einer wasserstelle die darunter
fließt einfluss habe ich schon mal ja
das ist sehr gute kann also ist der
zuckerrohr einem schluss und hier ist
auch schon eine höhle mit fackeln drin
genau das ist okay mannschaft direkt das
wasser runter schwimmst deinster toll da
unten dieser und da siehst doch holz
weide im holz das er gebaut ist aber
nicht gestorben ok ok ok wo bin ich
direkt davor und ich sehe deine items
komme ich kann dir sichern
troll ist nicht in sicht wo es änderte
sack dann und die grafische muster jetzt
lassen wir ausgespannt ok hat ihn
getötet
alter schwede wenn man sich einschreiben
kann ich das auf ich pass auf wir retten
ich komme zu den grabstein brauchen
jetzt schnell ok grabstein hab ich dann
muss sie ab in die stadt
ich habe kann ich die koordinaten ich
habe eine alte muss auch alle weist
ungefähr was es war weil ja die
koordinaten von der stadt kennen city zu
felde gar nicht ehrlich rosa oder weiß
in welche richtung es war von dir aus
also da wo es zuckerrohr ist da die
richtung eigentlich da wusste ich da ist
da noch zuckerrohr in die richtung also
an eigentlich google hoch an dem hügel
hoch ok bitte finde ich das jetzt älter
und bitte bekommen täuscht wichtig dass
ich mich jetzt da noch getäuscht also
werder ist ein großer großer wald
die eigentlich nicht mehr an ich sehe
die stadt lippstadt.de nicht nur
übersehen
weigert sich die hälfte bei der
zuschauer für ein gefäß point leute ok
es mit dem grab den friedhof finden und
dann kannst du wieder auf den server hat
zum glück nicht so lange gedauert wie
ich befürchtet habe die rettungsaktion
so sehr sehr gut
ich lag schon durch die stadttore da ist
auch schon der friedhof und dann würde
ich sagen darf natürlich auch 3d seinen
grabstein 31 platziert okay okay und ich
heute wieder ja wo ich bin hier zu leben
sehr sehr gut danke dir ja da wäre mir
damals nicht ganz gut leben zum portal
laufe ich bin hier wer bei dieser mega
brock politikum
ach so dann warte ich am besten schon
direkt hier weißt du schon was du so hat
ist dann werdet ihr die sachen direkt
raus ich hatte den reisen spitzhacke ein
paar fackeln und kohle eisen blöcke ein
paar 20 also ein paar sachen die man
anrufen ich hatte nicht den mega das
mega equipment noch mehr lohn hatte ich
und du etwas karotten die karotten dich
eigentlich nur melonen heute ein
glückstag ich hab nämlich direkt am
sport habe ich ordentlich essen
abgegriffen und davon kann ich dir gerne
auch mal ein bisschen was abdrücken
ich habe nämlich irgendwie 46 stakes die
ich direkt am anfang von diesen tellern
geholt da weißt du da warst findest du
es dann gibt es noch ein bisschen essen
ja ich habe vom rasen geholt und waren
ganz viele
ach so hast du sagen kannst du sonst
irgendwas essens mäßiges die sonst für
gar nichts aber ich habe jetzt von dir
doch mal zwölf fleisch das sollte
eigentlich passen okay okay
sollte ich mal in meine höhe führen
direkt ja gerne mit am start
ich hoffe mal dass ich dass ich die auch
direkt finde wieder hier oben ging es
irgendwo hoch weil die wangen sich waren
wir glaube ich auch in derselben höhe
also die koordinaten waren ja wirklich
sehr ähnlich
ich lass mir ging es runter ja genau
auch hier seid ihr unterm kiel hier sind
wir unter denke ich zumindest
daher hat sich am anfang manstein gut
aber hier besser wir haben wir können
kein wettmachen
so haben wir vielleicht schaue ich glaub
nicht also ich hatte mal dass statt 31
gesehen wie ich fahren wir mal ein
bisschen stein dass wir dir irgendwie
noch ein bisschen rüstung machen können
damit wir den ofen haben zwei
sondereffekte habe ich so genannte cold
cold sollte es dort tatsächlich hier
geht's sogar in die höhle
die hatten zugebaut ja okay ich komme
schon kräftig denn an gar nichts ich bin
nur durch durchfall starten eigentlich
lassen sind direkt über denn die andere
weil wir kurz das eisernen ofen backen
oder noch hier war ja machen wir das
vielleicht für manche so lang und als
rein ganze kohle da ein paar drei stücke
ja so schön wird der bestehe ich habe
ein bisschen kohle hingeworfen wenig
aufpassen eines fertigen hört sich ein
wenig kürzer das zu recht wobei deine
darf er trotzdem tolle stimmung die das
trotzdem volle 15 minuten lang seien nur
die leute mal an seine manche ja nicht
die die rettung gesehen
machst du auch direkt machst du auch
direkt 20 minuten folgen länge
eigentlich schon ja man so hatte ich so
geplant also man kann ja gerade zu
beginn hier viel machen man kann sich so
viele rohstoffe haben und so weiter und
das ist schon wichtig ist man dafür
schafft ich glaube auch dass ich das
machen werde wir wieder kein holz oder
hatte ich keins dabei du hattest 1 mit
dem wetter außer ich hab verloren
für typ sagt auch dass ich extra holz
geholt habe oder habe ich noch nichts
sagen wollt ich habe ein holz leder
platziert als ich mich einfach stimmt ja
das hätte ich holen müssen ausfall droht
okay okay wir müssen noch wirklich und
aufpassen in der nacht ist es
unglaublich gefährlich hier
ich glaub dir auch dass sie monster
gefährlich sind ich hab das schon
gesehen selbst solche kleinen monster
absaß das auch gehört was denn wenn wir
zum klingen gemacht ich habe nur ein
bisschen
okay wir wollen jetzt die die höhle
anschein ich glaube dass ich mir noch am
sichersten hier ein ja würde ich würde
ich sagen da ich warte nur von oven
gerade das denn wenn ich fertig schmilzt
man man man ist schon wieder spannend es
gibt hier so kreatur und so den
nitewatch zum beispiel der es ist wie so
ein ja so ein riesiges schweben das auge
und macht es halt irgendwie 80 leben
oder sowas und den will ich gar
natürlich bei nacht draußen angriff das
ja eben eher an den gibt es ja nur
weihnacht und deshalb sollten wir
wirklich aufpassen so ich mache diese
abladen nach dem atlas heißt ja dafür
brauchen wir brauchen wir dafür ein
verzaubertes buch das muss nicht
verzögert werden oder auch sony hier ist
einfach nur verzaubert ist training wie
ja ich glaube dass da was falsch ist
oder ob das private die ram pickup das
heißt das ding dass es neben einer
komplett den machen würde dem mit ihr
machen will ich noch dass wirklicher ich
habe schon zwei red und ich gebe dir
schon mal ein
dann machen wir uns auf jeden fall noch
den anti atlas und ich probiere noch mal
mein blatt magic altar zu machen
queenston ein bisschen vier queenston
und dann hätten wir sogar eigentlich ein
bisschen was geschafft einmal haben wir
erfolgreich dich gerettet
ich möchte auf jeden fall mal angucken
und der dann alter karte sonst was also
kann man nie sagen dass wir ein produkt
die sache noch nicht aber schaffe ich ja
weil ich auch noch ordentlich zeit habe
also wenig zu sehen
ja ich glaube aber auch dass sich in
krimis braucht leder aber ich glaube
jetzt sollte ich nicht nach oben geht
naja gefährlich 8 uhr du hast auch nur
leder oder wie
also mir fehlt jetzt auch leder für mein
buch drei rädern ii 1 1 1 1 erklärt noch
zwei leder jeweils okay so altar zack
zack zack zack tja ich kann mir mein
alter direkt fertig machen was und wohin
weil wir hatten auch ebenfalls schon
überlegt wegen dem grundstück in der
stadt wie man ja genau da müssen wir
noch mal schlafen und herren irgendwie
besprechen richtig also wenn ich könig
werden sollte irgendwann mal dann wäre
ich euch eure grundstücke alle wegnehmen
und beschlagen auf den unterthemen
bedingungen
ich habe so wähle ich dich das tut mir
leid aber okay natürlich mit der teil
der blut altar ist fertig lies okay aber
ich platzieren jetzt noch nicht ich muss
mir dafür sowieso noch ein bisschen was
besorgen sich damit irgendwie arbeiten
kann das ganze so gründe damit machen
mit blut alter und der blue tata ist die
grund grundlage der der blut magie und
ich könnte jetzt zum beispiel hergehen
und in dem blut alltag nachdem ich ein
bisschen von meinem eigenen blut
gespendet habe in dem ich mich selbst
verletzt ja klingt krass wie auch ein
bisschen aber nachdem ich davon ein
bisschen gespendet habe kann ich dann
einen diamanten reinwerfen und habe dann
den allerersten blatt ob der es mir
ermöglicht hat die energie von meinem
blut mitzunehmen
im total verrückt irgendwie aber mit
dieser energie die ich dann dabei habe
kann ich unter anderem später fliegen
mir eine rüstung machen die so lange die
mich so lange unbesiegbar macht wie noch
energie in meinem blut netzwerk ist er
verrückt war ja sage ich ja es ging doch
cool dass eine menge spaß
das ist richtig cool und ich glaube das
wird auch vor allen dingen wenn wir dann
tatsächlich in den krieg mit anderen
städten ziehen extrem lies sein
ja und auf jeden fall ist auch fliegen
später natürlich sehr wichtig dass man
schnell von a nach b kommt bist du schon
in hülle abgekommen
ich hab mich runter gegraben ist die
schlucht ich weiß nicht dass auf jeden
fall eine fackel da warst du glaub ich
schon mal hier drüben
rein gekommen deswegen wollen wir da mal
rein stecken
der blut alter hut bekommen die ganze
zeit welche geräusche ich weiß nicht was
kommt glaube ich immer dann wenn ich
irgendwie ins kinn hoch gelevelt habe
weise nicht kennst du die gerade dass
das passiert einerseits glaube wenn man
skills hochleveln und andererseits wenn
man irgendwelche sachen rennen findet
irgendwie so mann
man kann zum beispiel wenn man stein
abbaut einfach goldnuggets bekommen ok
so dass sie irgendwie ganz wichtig ist
mir schon zweimal passiert oder hier ist
eigentlich ja genau
ja da sind wir in der mine perfekt ja
nicht drin
wisst ihr leute so ich denke mir immer
so
20 minuten folgen findet ihr das auch
cool aber dann andererseits wenn ich
dann aufnehmen denk mir so hey du kannst
jetzt nicht aufhören so spannend und so
fiel plötzlich da doch noch machen und
sie eben hier kommen wir wie tekken die
kämpfer aus bzw
vielleicht finden wir ja sogar noch das
wäre wunderbar wenn wir hier noch was
finden würden guck mal hier siehst du
das hier ist sogar noch eine kiste
wasser kommt die chance mal ein paar
leute dafür braucht einen diamanten
spitzhacke ja richtig dafür braucht man
mit der spitzhacke hier ist noch mein
card mit love is einem tagebuch ein
tagebuch
die handbuch steht hier die hälfte also
okay du hast ja ja die übersetzten paket
ja ich hab das nicht weil ein paar
sachen gibt die halt nicht übersetzt
werden oder komisch oder so
dahinter war doch gerade koppel stone
noch ein bisschen weiter die mine
erkunden erklärte also die medien geht
auch da oben noch gut weiter
was ist denn hier los
wo denn er versinkt ihr so der gerade
eben gemacht
ach so wollen wir dafür hat und nur noch
mal nach oben bei um war noch was vorher
kommen wie eine die von oben wir sind
hier unter gesprungen
in den weg gebaut komme unmöglich meinst
du sie sollten spinnen wir mitnehmen
bringt uns das wasser weniger also ich
glaub spinnen wegen drogen vielleicht
aber aber ansonsten sind jetzt nicht was
sollen wir hier schönes haben wir die
fragliche platziert oder sind wir klar
wir kommen wieder so wie ja hier waren
wir glaube ich vorhin aber ich sah den
seiten noch nicht schon mal da drüben
ist noch lang
daher gehe ich mal erkunden so dauert
das schrecklich mit dem wasser her da
drüben noch mal richtig weiter habe ich
das gefühl ich habe ja wirklich also ich
kenne auf diesem teil vom höhlensystem
gar nicht wir haben also bett und ich
habe das höhlensystem er schon der
letzten folge gefunden
und okay sagen dass wir okay die nacht
ist sehr gut und ich war 20 minuten
absolut ich muss direkt vom server
wenn wir ein bisschen was weiter sehen
wollt dann geht bei ghom auf den kanal
schaut euch das an das war's mit dieser
folge und bis dahin tschüss